also die Bundesregierung will die
Zuwanderung erleichtern um den
Fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen Fachkräfte
mit Arbeitsvertrag sollen einfacher
kommen können aber auch Fachleute ohne
Vertrag sollen einreisen dürfen dann
allerdings nach einem Punktesystem es
zählen unter anderem wir haben es gerade
schon gehört Sprachkenntnisse oder aber
auch die Berufserfahrung dazu freue ich
mich jetzt ein Gespräch führen zu können
mit dem Oppositionsführer der
Unionsfraktion Friedrich Merz schönen
guten Morgen sie wollten sich das alles
mal vorurteilsfrei anschauen ich gehe
davon aus dass haben sie getan über das
was man bisher weiß gehen sie denn mit
mit den Vorschlägen der Ampel wir werden
heute Mittag von der Ampel mal wieder
hören wie schrecklich das alles in der
Vergangenheit war und wie wenig frühere
Bundesregierung getan haben an denen
auch die SPD beteiligt war wir haben in
Deutschland ein Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz wir brauchen mehr
und wir schöpfen die Potenziale die wir
schon jetzt haben nicht aus ich
Gewinnspiele haben in Deutschland 2,5
Millionen Arbeitslose auf als 1,9
Millionen offene Stellen da funktioniert
der Arbeitsmarkt nicht wir haben
Freizügigkeit in der Europäischen Union
aus allen Mitgliedstaaten der
Europäischen Union können Menschen nach
Deutschland kommen um hier zu arbeiten
ohne jede Bürokratie aber sie kommen
nicht weil die Bedingungen in
Deutschland einfach nicht gut genug sind
die Bürokratie ist furchtbar die Steuern
sind zu hoch und dann warten in den
deutschen Auslandsvertretungen im
Verantwortungsbereich von Frau bärburg
hunderte wenn ich tausende Fachkräfte
darauf endlich ein Visum zu bekommen und
sie bekommen es nicht weil die
Mitarbeiter nicht da sind und nicht
schnell genug arbeiten also das
Potenzial auch schöpfen wäre der erste
Schritt es ist ja auch so dass viele
Menschen dann vielleicht noch ein
erweiterter Punkt hier sind wo die
Qualifikation aber nicht anerkannt wird
würden sie sich denn dafür stark machen
und auch das soll sich ja verändern dass
das jetzt auch schneller passiert
absolut wir müssen über die Anerkennung
von Berufsabschlüssen sprechen aber das
Problem ist dass viele gar keinen haben
wir haben viele Menschen hier die in
Arbeitsmarkt in Deutschland einfach
nicht verwendbar sind wir bekommen nach
Deutschland viele Menschen die hier im
Arbeitsmarkt nicht unterzubringen sind
und die die wir brauchen wir wollen
nicht kommen also das ist etwas
komplexer als die Bundesregierung ist
aber da noch mal nachgefragt soll dann
z.B Arbeit dann ohne vorherige
Anerkennung also wenn die Fachkräfte
hier sind und das alles zu lange dauert
das hat ja auch ihr Fraktionsvize gesagt
frei dass das dann schneller geht dass
sie schon mal in Arbeit kommen weil es
gibt auch Menschen genug Menschen hier
die wir in Arbeit bringen könnten noch
mal wir haben viele die schon hier sind
und ich würde jetzt sagen wir
konzentrieren uns mal auf die die da
sind und sorgen dafür dass die so
schnell wie möglich in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert werden deswegen hatten wir ja
letzte Woche auch diese harte
Auseinandersetzung um das Bürgergeld im
Hartz 4 betrifft ja nicht nur deutsche
sondern betrifft auch viele Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund die hier in
Deutschland leben wir sind offen für
alle Diskussion verschließen uns
überhaupt nicht den guten Argumenten ist
auch noch weiter zu verbessern aber zu
behaupten wir müssen jetzt sozusagen bei
Null anfangen und das hat alles so
furchtbar schrecklich gewesen den
letzten Jahren die Behauptung ist und
wirklich viele Menschen auch nicht weil
natürlich die deutsche Sprache manchmal
abschreckend ist da hat natürlich das
Ausland Vorteile wenn dort Englisch
gesprochen wird auch da gibt es Ideen
und auf der anderen Seite muss man ja
sagen 400.000 das ist die Zahl die
gerade im Raum steht sollen pro Jahr
nach Deutschland kommen und das ist aus
dem Potenzial was sie gerade genannt
haben ganz zu Beginn nur mal nicht
auszuschöpfen also wir brauchen doch
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland bestreitet
das
wir wollen helfen dass das besser wird
aber der erste Schritt müsste doch sein
dann diejenigen zu nehmen die da sind
und nicht zusätzlich noch Einwanderung
sozusagen auszulösen in den Arbeitsmarkt
wir haben Erfahrungen damit wie das war
2015/20
wissen sie aber Flucht und Migration
Einwanderung weil ich will ihn mal aus
Zuwanderung von Fachkräften das sind
zwei völlig unterschiedliche Fachkräfte
sprechen uneingeschränkt ja dann müssen
wir die Bedingungen und die
Attraktivität des arbeitsstandorts
Deutschland verbessern damit die
Fachkräfte auch wirklich kommen wenn die
Koalition den Vorschlag macht werden wir
sicher nicht widersprechen aber wir
wollen Flucht und Asyl nicht mit
Fachkraft zu raten zu tun nur noch mal
ich erinnere an die Jahre 15 16 da haben
Teile der deutschen Wirtschaft in
höchsten Tönen begrüßt das jetzt endlich
die Fachkräfte kommen die wir brauchen
60% von denen sind in Hartz IV und viele
andere sind aber auch mittlerweile im
Berufen angekommen oder werden aber auch
ausgebildet und auch das gehört so
weiter zu dann lassen Sie uns über ein
anderes Thema sprechen wo es auch ganz
dringend Antworten auf Fragen braucht
und ganz sicherlich kein Populismus
nämlich das Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
soll ja reformiert werden Menschen heißt
es die eine Aufenthaltsgenehmigung haben
sollen jetzt früher deutsche
Staatsbürger werden können und zwar
anstatt nach acht Jahren bereits nach
fünf Jahren alle oder fast alle
Voraussetzungen die es bisher gibt
sollen dafür bleiben was ist ihr Problem
damit ich habe doch gar nicht gesagt
dass wir damit ein Problem haben
wir schauen uns genau an was die
Koalition vorhat wir reden zur Zeit über
drei verschiedene Sachverhalte wir
sprechen im dieser Woche über das
sogenannte chanceneinwanderungsrecht da
geht es praktisch nur um Asylbewerber
die abgelehnt worden sind wir sprechen
dann anschließend über die Fachkräfte
Einwanderung das ist der Gegenstand von
heute und dann werden wir irgendwann
auch über das Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
sprechen und da sagt sogar die FDP das
ist ein bisschen vorschnell was die
Koalition da macht was interessant
bisher März denn da steht seit einem
Jahr in dem Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel
also ist ein bisschen beruhigen
mit der FD sprechen und ich mit mir das
hat uns auch überrascht war ist das hier
natürlich über Staatsbürgerschaft reden
können aber dann muss die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft am Ende der
Integration stehen und nicht am Anfang
und sagen Sie das immer wieder am Ende
der Integration da steht doch gar nicht
im Zweifel denn wenn man sich die
Voraussetzung Moment Bedingung für die
Einbürgerung
rechtmäßiger Aufenthalt Bekenntnis zur
freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung
Besitz eines unbefristeten angelegten
Aufenthaltsrecht eigenständige Sicherung
des Lebensunterhalts ausreichend
Deutschkenntnisse und ich könnte noch
weitere Punkte nennen also dass die
Punkte sind aber auch nicht der Anfang
von dass die Punkte sind dann können wir
darüber reden aber wenn die Fristen so
deutlich verkürzt werden wenn die
Ansprüche zum Beispiel an die deutsche
Sprache
reduziert werden insbesondere bei den
älteren die hier leben dann müssen wir
darüber reden wir sind nicht dagegen wir
gucken uns das an und unsere Aufgabe als
Opposition ist wir gucken uns das
kritisch an bei it-lern da gehen sie
wahrscheinlich mit ist es sinnvoll weil
die Sprache ist sowieso Englisch und sie
haben einen Punkt bei Senioren und
Senioren die schon länger hier leben
sagt man okay das mit der deutschen
Sprache kann man jetzt auch vergessen
das ist vielleicht so eine Art
Anerkennung der Lebensleistung wo sie im
Punkt haben ist bei Senioren in Senioren
die jetzt kommt da soll dann die
deutsche Sprache eben Punkt über das
über den man sprechen muss und ich will
es noch mal ganz einfach sagen wenn wir
in Deutschland insgesamt bessere
Bedingungen im Arbeitsmarkt hätten ich
habe eben die Steuern schon genannt ich
habe die Bürokratie in Deutschland
genannt ich habe die Auslandsvertretung
genannt hätten wir das Problem in diesem
Umfang nicht also es gibt im bestehenden
System einem Menge mehr Möglichkeiten
die Einwanderung nach Deutschland zu
verbessern und da sind wir in jeder
Hinsicht dafür und was ist ganz zum
Schluss noch mit dem Thema doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft also der sogenannte
Doppel pastin ist ja schon gibt 2021
Betrug da die mehr staatenquote bei der
Einbürgerung 69% ist das nicht einfach
die Anerkennung der Wirklichkeit
trotzdem bleibt es ein Problem es sind
doppelte Loyalitäten wir finden wir
sollten vorsichtig damit umgehen wir
wissen dass es viele Fälle gibt auch
viele Familien gibt es gibt viele
Situationen da sind die Kinder
automatisch mit einer zweiten
Staatsangehörigkeit ausgestattet um
politische Teilhabe umwählen dürfen
nichts dagegen wenn man Teil dieser
Gesellschaft ist ja trotzdem erlauben
Sie uns dass wir etwas genauer
hinschauen das ist nicht zum
Dauerzustand und zum Regelfall wird das
jeder und alle in Deutschland die
doppelte oder die dreifachen
Staatsangehörigkeiten haben so und das
macht jedes Land der Welt warum nicht
auch Deutschland sagt Friedrich Merz der
Vorsitzende der CDU und
Oppositionsführer im Deutschen Bundestag
danke ihnen sehr gesprächig